jo-ann's with us in San Antonio hi
Joanne how are you hi how are you Dave
Ramsey better than I deserve how are you
I'm great
my question is I'm listening to the news
and they're saying that President Obama
is signing a student loan debt
forgiveness and if you've had your
student loan for over 20 years and you
haven't missed a payment then you could
do apply for this debt forgiveness I've
been paying on my student loans for 15
years and the balance doesn't seem to be
going down at all but what is that the
balance is 29,000 what do you what's
your household income it's at 50,000 why
is your balance not going down I don't
know I can just play interesting I'm I
did in the beginning when I was only
making 20,000 a year but for the past
seven years I've been paying 250 and it
just doesn't seem to move the balance is
just stayed the same you're not living
on a written budget and you have other
debt don't you I have a vehicle debt how
much you owe on your car it's at nine
thousand okay and I have my two to three
months of emergency fund or yet in place
how much is that I have five thousand
okay and you're single
yet okay all right well what I would
tell you to do is let's get you on a
written budget and let's cut your
expenses down enough and then let's
clean up your $29,000 in debt and your
$9,000 in car debt making $50,000 a year
in about a year and a half to two years
because I'm gonna put I'm gonna put you
on beans and rice rice and beans nothing
and clean up this mess
the downside of President Obama's
program is is it's going to cause people
to make the decision to stay in debt
longer rather than clean up their mess
and it's not it's going to
to hold you back for another five years
and I kiddo I want you free and right I
like most government programs this is a
lame one and so he's trying to do a good
thing but when you use the government to
do a good thing it always turns into a
bad thing and there's no exception here
so I mean we there's people sitting
around right now going I'm just going to
wait twenty years up and then I'm not
going to pay my bill and that's no way
to live your life people don't let the
government dumb you down
so now Joanna let me put you through
Financial Peace University hold on I'll
have Kelly pick up and I want you to go
to our nine week class on how to handle
money I'll pay for it I'll give it to
you because I want you to live free and
with dignity and in control and you're
going to have to have you're going to
have to have a year and a half to two
years of hell you can live on nothing
you know sell so much stuff the dog
thinks it's next it's going to be garage
sales in your future in craigslist and
ebay and you're not going to be in a
restaurant you're not only taking
vacations but you can clean up this mess
once and for all
and get out of your life and stop
borrowing money and don't look for the
government to come along on a white
horse and fix your life because they
can't they can't you know you don't want
to wait five more years and buy the next
five years two hundred and fifty
thousand dollars will flow through your
fingertips while you wait on a
government program I wouldn't do it I
wouldn't do it and I just think this and
that's yet another reason I think this
is just a horrid program and I don't
care if it's Republicans or Democrats
you know guys and I know whether you're
trying to help I know they are but the
problem is is they demotivate people in
the midst of it and these people are
going to sit on the sidelines I stay in
this ridiculous mess that is their lives
while they wait on Obama to save their
life oh my gosh it's just horrible
people it's just awful so it's a problem
when you wait on the government to do
things for you this this this country
was designed not for the government to
fix your life
there's designed for you to have
freedoms and liberty and the opportunity
for you to fix your life and you're just
much better off if you do that you're
going to come out way ahead if you go
that route you're going to come out way
ahead
and so there may be one or two instances
where this program works for you I got
to tell you most of time what it does is
it unplugs normal thinking and
common-sense thinking and it puts you in
a real slowed-down molasses you know
your life moves at the speed of molasses
it really slows down to nothing and it
just just it's awful just awful
so now I just distressing and are they
ever going to stop like the government
needed more expenses they're already
just spending money like water up there
well just dumb just don't
you